He calls himself a doctor.
Deep sea.
That's what we're going to call him, too.
Diving explorer and medical researcher
Joseph De
Terry just broke
the world
record for the longest time,
living underwater at ambient pressure.
Today is a 76th of living
at the Jules
Undersea Lodge habitat in Key
Largo, Florida.
And part of his research
is to see
what living at 22 feet
underwater does to the human body.
Joseph Detroit is joining us
live now from his underwater lab.
How are you feeling, Doctor?
I mean,
what do you think
this does to the human body?
I am so good.
It's coming on.
I'm very honored to be on your show.
Thank you so much.
So what do I think it does
to the human body?
We had a null hypothesis that
that we would get better
sleep and
increase or decrease
our inflammatory markers in our body.
And the first round of blood tests
came back and said,
yeah, that's absolutely true.
We decreased every inflammatory marker in
my body,
and my sleep has been so much better.
About 60% deep in REM sleep.
So we're really excited about that.
I mean, that's significant.
What are the factors that you think
are contributing to that?
The things
maybe that you don't have underwater
or that you don't have underwater
that we experience
and maybe stress us out a little bit
at surface at surface
right?
Well, it's the second,
third order consequences
that come from
being in a hyper
meaning more than apparent
meaning pressure environment.
So I'm in a hyperbaric environment
right now,
and this is the exact same
depth and pressure
at which I treat
traumatic brain injury and PTSD.
So we knew that the inflammatory markers
were going to go down
because that's a mechanism of action
of hyperbaric medicine.
But I'm actually at the pressure of £25
per square inch,
which is exactly where I treat
TBI and PTSD.
So we're watching
some of your daily routine,
but take us through what it is
like throughout the day
to live underwater as you do
Easy.
So I usually wake up at between four
and 5 a.m.
only because I'm an early riser.
Always have been.
I'm in New York or I just got up early.
It's my mom's fault. Blame her.
I get up.
I get a couple of cups of coffee
because I can tell you
that science does not happen
without coffee.
And then I roll through my list
and we're doing EKGs, EEGs,
blood sample
urine, saliva,
all that stuff on a daily basis.
And, you know,
I'm trying to find out what happens
in the isolated,
confined, extreme environment,
which is very much akin to space travel.
So we're going to be stuck in that tube
for 200 days to get to Mars.
This is just a preliminary experiment
to figure out
what happens when you're stuck
in a tube underwater for 100 days.
So half the time
we need a couple more times on this.
So what what other reasons?
I mean,
if this could be
sort of a bit of a test case
for what it is to travel to Mars
what are the other reasons
that you need
this research in this experience?
Oh, the one thing that was a
totally intended
consequence is the STEM outreach to kids.
We are so excited about that.
We've reached over
2500 kids, person-to-person
over Zoom calls
with people in landlocked states,
kids out there
that are thinking about careers
in science, technology,
engineering and math.
And we're talking to them
about preserving,
protecting and rejuvenating
the marine environment.
60 to 70% of the oxygen
comes from the world's oceans.
And we have to have those kids start
taking better care than we did,
unfortunately, better care
than we did of the oceans,
so that we can keep giving back that life
sustaining oxygen
that we absolutely need.
And plus, science is cool.
I mean, you know,
I'm not maybe I'm not quite so cool,
but science can be very cool.
And you can do it in a fun environment,
like in the water.
Yeah. Science is cool.
60% REM sleep is cool, too,
I'll tell you that. Dr.
Nutri,
it is wonderful
to have you from your undersea
lab there in Key Largo, Florida.
Thank you for joining us.
Absolutely.
A pleasure. Thank you for having me.